there are growing questions tonight
about some of the spending practices at
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development under new secretary ben
Carson correspondent Peter Doocy looks
at the allegations that while cuts were
being made in services for Americans
money was spent freely on furniture and
decor you might think the cabinet member
who spent 31,000 taxpayer dollars on a
dining set would be the secretary of
interior decorating but it's not the new
owner of a dining set that costs as much
as an Audi Housing and Urban Development
Secretary ben Carson the dining set
heading for his private dining room at
HUD costs six times more than the five
thousand dollar budget for upgrades like
this unless Congress cuts a bigger check
which didn't happen a HUD spokesman
emailed Fox quote thanks for reaching
out I'll get you something that was at
11:26 a.m. so no word on what's changed
in secretary Carson thoughts on federal
budgets since his days as candidate
Carson anybody who tells me you can't
like Nancy Pelosi you can't reduce by
one penny or it will be a complete
disaster because we are 100% efficient
what a bunch of crap Carson isn't the
only administration official whose eye
popping expenditures have drawn scrutiny
during Trump's tenure former HHS
Secretary Tom Price had to resign when
the president soured on his use of
private jets and two others EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt and VA
secretary David Shulkin have recently
had their travel invoices poured over as
questions arose about high-priced fares
or family members flying along all this
despite working for a commander-in-chief
who signed an executive order last year
directed at eliminating Washington's
waste this order requires a thorough
examination of every executive
department and agency to see where money
is being wasted how services can be
improved now Democrats on Capitol Hill
are pledging to give Carson a former
neurosurgeon a thorough exam what is
appropriate
investigation by the Government
Accounting Office into whether there's a
violation of what's known as the
anti-deficiency Act now Republicans are
investigating two in the last hour
Oversight Committee Chair trey Gowdy
told HUD to preserve all documents about
redecorating he is trying to see if
there's merit to a HUD employees claim
that they got demoted when they wouldn't
blow the budget Brett will follow it
Peter thank you